let me give in a small example I don't
shake hands with women and that creates
a huge issue because every single person
second person I see the hospital is the
woman but if I explain to them that you
know I shake my I put my hands here and
I say you know work I have a pact with
my wife I don't shake hands or hug young
young women like yourself and my wife
does the same to honor or marriage and I
hope that we can understand I don't mean
to offend you
95% of people will appreciate that there
are some people who take offense you
can't really make everyone happy hmm
there have been instances wherein one
person she actually got her cellphone
out and she died her husband and so you
know I want to speak to you this doctor
and he she asked me to tell him what I
just did Wow
yeah she like like she like she liked it
she liked it she said that you know what
we really want people to keep their
hands to himself especially this way we
really want people to keep their hands
to themselves perceive all the six
candles in our days yes what's happening
right now if we can explain to them that
you know what in the way of life that I
follow that has been taught to me by
Mohamed Salah rissalah we respect and
honor women and for that reason these
are protections that we have that you
know what leave alone now the Billa
harassing them we don't even touch them
as if unless they are very close earlier
to us like my wife my sister or my
daughter or my mom and women really
appreciate that even men appreciate that
just pick two days ago it I mean it
happens to me almost every day because I
every day I see a new patient there was
an older gentleman in the bed I went in
and I introduced myself and I'm doctor
I'm a so and so and there was his
grandson and the grandsons girlfriend so
she explained her Hannah I explained
this so the both the girl and the
boyfriend both of them were happy is
like you know there's something there's
something that we should think of if we
get married if we get married so that
you know we keep our bond strong yeah so
Islam a lot Allah has put this
discussion this you know attraction in
it but we have to present it in a nice
way
most of the time people understand and
there are some people will not
understand yeah and these other people
you know who a lot the last put you know
veil on their heart yeah and you know
that we have to be dis prepared because
we can't make everyone happy this yeah I
like that I'm gonna I
that's a nice slogan we keep our hands
to ourselves and especially like I said
in today's day and age
yes tell I just do a little you know
work my wife accused me on a short leash
yeah she doesn't want my hands to touch
any other woman and you have all of
these wine stains in this person this
Hollywood producer you got people you
know not just keeping our hands to
ourselves lowering our gaze now being
alone with the opposite gender and if
you implement those things all of these
and explain them and explain that it's
the context I think because for example
just same thing if I just say you know
what I don't shake hands
yeah then you have not explained why you
did then she will think oh maybe she's
studying thinking because women are
inferior in his mind or maybe he has
nothing to do with that nothing nothing
to do so then you it depends on if you
have good conversation most of the time
this opens up an avenue for Dawa yes you
tell them then you know I do this
because not because I think you're
unclean because my mom is a woman my
wife my daughter my teachers not I think
not because I think you're in fear
because you are sacrosanct your sacred
for me you know you are someone's
daughter someone's wife someone's mother
and that's why I want to keep my hands
to myself yeah I think any reasonable
woman will understand where I'm coming
any reasonable human being to understand
that just makes sense thank you very
much there's a pleasure same Avenue
Kazan go ahead inshallah doc - we'll
have you back again
thank you very much el Aslam o alaikum
Salaam
you